(playful music)
- Hi, my name is Jim Beagle,
I'm one of the owners at
Grapery along with Jack Pandol.
And today we're in a
cotton candy vineyard.
We're involved in a breeding program
where we breed new grape varieties.
It's all natural, non-GMO
and we've been able to come up with
some really great flavors in grapes.
One of the first ones is cotton candy
but we have many more to come.
You know, just to see
people eating healthy
and enjoying eating healthy,
it really motivates us.
- Cotton candy grapes?
Never heard of such a thing.
- I don't know how a grape
can taste like cotton candy.
- The fact that you're
telling me this grape
is gonna taste like candy, creeps me out.
- They smell like normal grapes.
- Here we go, woo!
- Oh, that's so weird!
- Whoa, that tastes like cotton candy.
- Oh my God. Oh my goodness
I can taste it.
- I can taste the cotton candy.
- Wow
- For sure.
- I feel like I'm at the ballpark
or the old carnival.
- If I burped in someone's face right now
they'd be like, "Dude, you've
been eating cotton candy.".
- It's like a flavor
tripping type of thing.
You're expecting one thing,
but then you get something
that's slightly different.
- Now I don't know if I know what
cotton candy tastes like anymore.
- It's like what you
wish when you were a kid,
like, "I wish this salad in my
mouth tasted like a pizza.".
- I think these'll be great for kids
cuz it'll encourage them to eat fruit
because it's fruit that tastes like candy.
- Society teaches the kids that
vegetables and fruit is gross,
but like it tastes so good.
- Fruits and vegetables are delicious.
- If you're gonna breed candy into fruit,
I'm in love with you.
(playful music)
- I don't think I would want my wine
to taste like cotton candy though.
- Certainly not.